let me take them one at a time and you
notice I have my quadrants drawn up okay
my quadrants because this is going to be
very helpful when we take into account
this information to you about the
restrictions on theta okay so number 1
cos theta stay on 5 theta is acute right
away when I see this I know I'm in only
one of the quadrants I'm in the first
quadrant ok so what I do is I take this
and I ignore the rest of the diagram
okay so maybe you're like what what a
waste
ok so really really what I could have
done when I read this I only really
needed to draw the first quadrant okay
but anyhow it's there nonetheless cos
theta is 3 on 5 ok
so remembering that I mean this only has
to be rough because just for the sake of
illustration but to make it roughly like
at least vaguely to scale ok I can see
that this is gonna be my 3 and this is
gonna be my 5 right because if Theatre
is there then I've got the Jason on
hypotenuse adjacent on hypotenuse okay
with that so you can see five along
there you'll notice by the way this is
not the unit circle anymore is it okay
it's a circle of radius 5 okay but
because the unit circle and all other
circles are similar that's why we use
all the ratios are the same no matter
the size of the circle now we use
Pythagoras this is an easy this is the
Pythagorean triad so this number of
course is and I believe if I'm you
memory says quickly then what sine and
tan so I won so from this you literally
read off the diagram slightly is
opposite on five partners tan theta is
opposite on adjacent I'll just take this
moment to notice the fact that if we
consider this line here it's like here
going going upwards
if we consider its equation if I said y
equals something right it's going to be
well all straight lines are MX plus B
right MX plus B what's the big one what
does B stand for B is the y-intercept
which in this case is zero so it's just
give me y equals something X something X
right and M of course is the radiance
which is rise over run rise over run now
I could write for every three because
those are the numbers but it would be
more interesting for me to write
it's just ten the gradient of a straight
line is just and it always is ten of
whatever angle you're hitting the actor
sir we'll deal with that in more depth
later I just want to point out because a
simple enough question that you're not
confused by the rest of it tuck that
away for later let's have a go at this
one
okay rehearse with me again I see this
information and what's the first thing I
do the first thing I do is I gotta keep
around where I draw my triangle and
that's based on the fact of theatres of
Q so which Quadra my in number two great
take that and I again all the rest now
because it's a bit trickier with the
negative right they're going to be some
things here which I want you to watch
carefully for so put your pens down for
a second the tribe was gonna be on this
side going off in the same direction
okay now I draw my scale really badly
just cuz cuz they go okay that's a
little bit better now I've got my right
angle there now we are used to writing
feet are in the corner connects to the
origin right but I cannot possibly write
feet of here can anyone tell me why
theta can't be there because these are
just very good I'm in a triangle right
where is Theta really yeah they're good
remember on there on the unit circle on
circles we start measuring from over
here and we go anti-clockwise
that's your obtuse angle so that's the
Thada okay but when we're looking at
this triangle and doing the ratios and
that kind of thing this angle in here is
the angle related to theta right so if
this was like a 150 okay they're related
angle will be on the wake excellent okay
good so just it's a minor thing but I
think it's helpful to show you
understand what's really going on
because this is kind of like there but
not really I put it as a feed up with
brackets around it I can take it I am
working in this triangle but that evil
air is not the real theta because of
what I know about it
okay all right now in a similar way
right
I have tan so this is which two sides
which resides well again opposite and
adjacent right so I could write this as
5 over 12 because all lengths are
positive right but as you can see
because I'm in the second quadrant right
this is not really 12 is it it's
actually minus 12 I'm going to the left
right now this does indicate a leg sir
just like here I'm gonna put a kind of
it's really negative okay
so minus 5 over 12 perhaps is not the
most accurate to say it it's really 5 /
- 12 cuz I'm in the second quadrant
okay but anyhow there you go that's
gonna be very useful for me in a second
when I work out side and sec whoops okay
so I could say all right I've got sign
over here and that's opposite by
hypotenuse right so 512 hypotenuse is 13
okay so I could think oh I'm in the
second quadrant suicide must be positive
so it must be 5 or about 13 right yeah
that's fine okay but have you noticed
that these numbers have the signs
attached to them I can just say it's 5
on 13 like I'd have to worry about which
corner I mean I've labeled the signs
already okay when I do it a sec right
say key is one cause
right so what's cause which two sides my
linking out adjacent and hypotenuse now
I see the adjacent side is really a
negative length right so this should be
one over adjacent on hypotenuse which of
course is minus thirteen eleven twelve
right so you could say oh I'm in the
second quadrant a s T C cause it's not
positive it's negative or alternately
you could just do the signs right from
the beginning and then you can read off
the numbers which I kind of prefer I
will encourage you as much as possible
like I said like I used to do that
actually because it's faster okay
however I find it more error-prone I
find out more air pure because I get
confused about which signs are which
especially when I'm like going over here
where they're both negative or over here
and I'm like which one's negative again
I just find it so much easier
unlike look there's the axes this is
going to the left it's clearly negative
right so I don't think it's a huge
time-saving and I think it helps clarify
what's going on
yeah yeah that's exactly right
so and it's much it's much harder to
remember them because we don't work with
them very much but obviously they match
the signs of their reciprocals but this
makes me nervous
sorry yeah no I was doing that to
clarify to you guys which ratio really
usually yeah you can but again any time
like just generally speaking can I just
do this in my head the answer that
depends on two things number one does
that process like demonstrating that
process is that an important part of
demonstrate you understand what's going
on our reciprocal functions really
what's being assessed to you know really
what's going on is can you draw this
triangle correctly and interpret science
properly right that's not the focus so
if this wasn't here this would lose them
up okay so firstly is it required
demonstrate understanding firstly
secondly as you gotta get it right like
if you're like me I'm kind of suspicious
of the fact that am I gonna flip it
right the round right around the ramp
way properly the first time
possibly not so I just write it down
again it's like a huge time cost and
when you're in exam and you are adding
more chance of areas because you're
Russian or like I'm through I just need
you might as well